so is there any way to prove that
pigeons never existed
or can be only not be proven to exist
it's actually I think these question
hinges on the only way you live and what
you mean by pigeons what is meant by
pigeons
right so today it's going to decide
pigeons which is to say that there are
these systems of commissions which are
created when people come from different
language background and they have to
communicate they have to speak to each
other so like in Africa in in Asia in
fact when pidgin arose in the coast of
China and it referred to this business
language that people used to cross
linguistic barriers so from that
perspective pigeons do exist right if
you take it as the definition pigeons
have been documented over and over again
there are no native languages and
typically they are indeed reduce in
instructure but as people use them more
and more
you know they can they can develop
structure so right so so this is what we
need to be clear about how we define
pigeons right because we looked at the
way Bickerton defined it right so the
claim was a very strong one that in the
history of creole you have this earlier
speech system that extremely meat using
structure and it was very precise in
terms of what's missing and what's
missing is a fixes so no no bits of
words that can be used to create larger
words so you don't have things like in
in English finger right so that's a very
extremely precise claims that claim
according to which pigeons are supposed
to be had to have the no bottom level of
language complexity they are really
simply system possible in fact even an
language like they might remind a say of
a language of Homo erectus
so that that that claim is a strong one
that we're looking at so in the
innovation Creole
according to the evidence that we have
we don't see any thing of that sort as
documented so the earliest archival data
shows that we have a full fledge
language with all the bells and whistles
including affixes embedding a very
complex language you know from the very
earliest stages you see we get you seem
to have some doubts about like like we
can know if there was no recording of
there being a pigeon like we like if
there is a recording okay just because
there's no recording can we not say that
oh maybe that was like spoken one right
but it was never yeah I can see what you
like you thank you drive that well you
could say that okay so actually bigger -
let's use something of that that kind of
argument well the way put it I put it
very subtly since that the absence of
evidence is not evidence of absence
right which is exactly are you trying to
claim here the fella could have
particular kind of data is that evidence
that didn't exist it might have existed
but money recorded it okay but in this
you know you're right the claim is
stronger that it you know it's a back if
it could have existed in the body could
be attention because it could have
existed and be part of a community to
the to the point where children being
born in the community would have used
that evidence to create the Creole right
remember that this is what you what you
get you have at some point it's let's
call it generation let's call it zero
okay and for that generation all the
hearing is I think I'm going to have to
use a stronger market Rachel will you
help me with this one with might work
oh yeah okay so so so there would have
been enough of this kind of data for
these children then to use that and then
from that create the Creole right so
it's not as if that this would have been
a very fleeting type of language so
given that they were they were observers
of the speech patterns that period
people wrote about the patterns of the
of the Africans you see it would have
been surprising if it was indeed
communal lingua franca of sorts and
nobody noticed that well there was the
system where all the French officials
were gone you see what one could could
could could imagine along your line or
since that maybe the men have been some
Africans who who will be producing
something that could be pigeon light
which would which would be like a second
language version of French which is what
we expect right because if you if you
learning
I don't know Italian you might go to a
state where you put use Italian verbs
without affixes right it forgotten
perspective yes one could imagine that
there would be some speakers producing
pidgin like data right but could there
be a whole community that will be using
the pigeon including say people in in
their own homes to the point where the
children would be only getting because
remember that for Bickerton
you know the crucial 50s is that you
have children here you see and the
children are transforming this pigeon
into a Creole and then you get at a
later generation this is called the
Serrano well plus one oh then you get
the creole becoming a stable language
from the pigeon
people sighs would it be then like
people are keeping their languages being
developed at the same time what people
keep in their African languages yeah in
fact the days report so someone actors
Olivia trio for example you know the
well-known Haitian leader was claimed to
also speak African languages from say
the bay family right so this is this is
likely that one could imagine that at
some point there will be many speakers
in the community would be bilingual or
trilingual even speaking foreign
languages but the question here is
whether there was anything like when
Bickerton posits that was spoken across
community to the point where the
children had no choice but to use only
this speech and data to create the
native Creole and the evidence is not
there and also structurally and this is
what we see so maybe we should come back
that question when we look at the data
because going to come back to the data
that we have and try to make sense of
this thing if you think about the
situation with Spanish there with
English in the u.s. it's very I mean I
wouldn't I would say that there's
several generations that speak it I also
would say that it's relatively unstable
in the way that a pidgin might be but I
also wouldn't know what the difference
would be between an unstable pidgin and
code switching in the sense that like if
you think about more of a modern-day
example I would say that Spanglish is
the best candidate but that also is my a
that would Tingley should be anything
like a pigeon right and in first of all
I would say that the conditions that
surround Spanglish are very different
from those that surrounded say the
creation of the haitian creole so in
terms of justin mix you see so in
Haitian Creole devastation will have
lots of Afghani which is being spoken
and plus many varieties of French
doesn't just want french were many
languages that for now called French but
in fact they were quite different in
the structure what the French themselves
called the path one right looking at
that definition then technically the
only pigeons would be the very very
first languages like so then like you
can't have Creole be a pigeon because it
influenced well that's what we're going
to see exactly that that in a way there
is a sense in which you know by by using
that because it's that close right from
pigeons you're really creasing bias
against the idea that you know the the
Africans actually they were learning
French in the same way say that the
French people themselves in Europe back
when French was being created we're
learning Latin and in fact we went to
look at some data like that ok so let's
so this is this is all good so you guys
have been I've been asking all the right
questions